[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use
in your everyday life hi i'm dan haynes
and i'm joined by my co-host
dr greg sandler and today we are talking
about
pitfalls to labeling people good or
bad so there's a lot of things that
we're going to talk about with this why
don't
you give the the lead-in about what you
had in mind and talking about these
these pitfalls so just the idea of
like labeling someone as uh like
unadulterated good or
evil this idea of like someone has like
a purely good character or like a purely
evil character and that's
uh that then transfers that goodness or
that evilness to
all the actions that they might take
throughout their entire lives and how
this way of thinking about uh
yourself and others has a lot of
downsides not that we can't use the
words good or bad but we should be
really
careful about how these words can
lead us to some potentially negative
outcomes
yeah it reminded me as you were saying
that about you know like in mathematics
we said well one thing is equal to
another thing or we use these metaphors
of like you know from a good tree comes
good fruit or
this this transfer that we
seem to assume takes place for a good
person
they're always going to be doing good
actions and so when we see them doing
something that's kind of sketchy we're
like well they must have a good reason
for it or somebody who we think is bad
you know even if they do something good
we're like well they must have some
nefarious purposes behind what they're
doing
even though they are helping the old
lady across the street it's probably so
they can mugger
afterwards or just to look good enough
that we they can take us
off our guard and you know it it could
be i suppose not just their actions but
maybe
also people connected to them so from
good parents we should expect really
good children
right or vice versa and then we're
surprised and we find out that somebody
who you know is a really great person
turned out to have awful
parents or siblings or co-workers or
things
things like that so why do you think
people
buy into this why why do people
need others or themselves to be like
totally good or totally bad
i think to a certain extent it's just an
easy heuristic
a heuristic is just an idea of a rule of
thumb that
usually results in good answers and so
it's a
uh if you go to like what daniel
kahneman's um and alex versky's book
thinking fast and slow you've got like
uh
thinking fast where you like oh i can
you know come to a conclusion about
something
and and you know ninety percent of the
time that it's the correct
outcome and that's really good because
it takes a lot less
mental capacity to do that but if i want
to actually think about things step by
step and really get into the nuance
that it's actually really uh difficult
both like
in brain power the caloric expenditure
to actually do that
and so you know we're our bodies are
like yeah
let's optimize these things we don't
want to be uh using all those
calories to like look at the nuance or
everything let's let's have some hard
and fast rules and it's you know
uh they work most the time and they get
us through life but you know
sometimes they're very wrong
yeah and i suppose we could go beyond uh
without you know saying that the
biological stuff isn't there
we could also say there's cultural
factors that some
some groups are um you know they tend
more to
labeling people like that and others
maybe
encourage more nuance or discrimination
we could say
um although we'd have to you know
specify which ones we're
we're talking about there and and avoid
falling into calling like one the good
group and one the bad group in that
respect as well
yeah um and and you you see this happen
with
oh the first thing that comes to mind is
uh yeah
um the hutus and the tutsis at um
in rwanda and they're you know same
people
and they they a artificial designation
was
used to uh divide up this population it
was
based upon the colonial powers saying
the uh one group was the good group
because they were the taller group
and longer yeah yeah more european
longer heads or something and then they
use that to
pit these this people against each other
and uh demonized one to the point where
you know neighbors were
unfortunately hacking up other neighbors
it was you know
absolutely reprehensible but it was you
know they applied this label a bad
against this one group and allowed that
to be
morally you know at least at that moment
to be you know
expected that you're going out to stop
the bads
yeah and and you know it's interesting
this this is a little bit off topic but
um you know i do a lot of work on anger
research and in philosophy and one of
the things that thomas aquinas says that
i think is like totally on point about
anger is that
it it realizes that it's imposing
something bad on somebody else you know
so you you impose an
evil as he says a male on on somebody
else
but in this case it's okay because it's
somehow like setting things right
so it's part of a bigger picture like
maybe you're doing it because you're
retaliating against them you're paying
them back for something they did or
you know they shouldn't have crossed a
certain line or they they impeded you in
something that you yourself desire
and so what we can recognize as
generally bad
when we're angry and we i think we could
say something similar about hatred too
we come to view that as as a good
and then we can justify doing all sorts
of things to people you know you you
you think about people too who will say
things like you know
if you hurt me i'll hurt you seven times
uh and it just sort of ratchets it up or
as we say escalates
things um i think part of the
the mindset behind that because there's
not that many people who just say
as as faust did evil be thou my good
right
most people are doing things that are
bad harmful injurious
to other people because they do see it
in some respect
as as something good or reasonable
for them to do so you know looking at
these mindsets where people
label themselves label their friends
label their enemies
as totally good or totally bad is
uh yeah i think this could be quite
so uh what was this uh from alexander
satsang that you wanted to talk about
yeah so he had this great quote and now
he's somebody who suffered quite a lot
right
he if you if you don't do you know his
backstory i think i don't
oh so he was in world war ii
and i believe he was in a in the tank
core you know
on the russian side fighting against the
the germans
and he got sent to the gulags and the
reason he did is because he
he made a joke about stalin in one of
the letters that he was sending
back home and the kgb would um
uh they'd open everybody's letters and
take a look to see if there was anything
that they shouldn't
you know have in there and making a joke
about the great leader
was you know that was enough to get you
sent to the gulags and the gulags
were these prisons that were not just
prisons
they were essentially they were work
camps and they were death camps
so the idea was that you know the
russians and they'd been doing this
you know long before the communist
revolution
and the the you know communist state
they'd been sending people to siberia
to to be you know outside of russian
society and then also to slowly
convert this this uh wilderness very
tough wilderness too
into something that would be livable for
for russians
sort of colonizing and civilizing it
and it was incredibly um
uh expensive in terms of lives but they
had many many people and this is one way
to sort of kill two birds with one stone
you take your political prisoners and
send them out there
work them you know giving them very
little food until they eventually die of
exposure malnutrition or
you know the guards beat them or
something along those lines or or kill
themselves out of despair so
socia nitsan got sent into the you know
he'll later publish a three volume set
of books called the gulag archipelago
these
these camps that were spread all
throughout siberia
and um so he got to see a lot of
human nature in its very unvarnished
state close up and so this is the thing
that he had to say
about evil and good he said if only
there were evil
people somewhere insidiously committing
evil deeds
and it were necessary only to separate
them from the rest of us and destroy
them
but the lines the line dividing good and
evil cuts through the heart of every
human being
and who is willing to destroy a piece of
his own heart
so there's a couple things going on
there the the very last thing
you know maybe there there is some
badness within
most of us i'll say there's certainly
some within me
and we're reluctant to look at it we're
reluctant to take it out and so it's
it's easy to call ourselves good
and just pretend like everything is is
wonderful and then we project it outward
the badness onto other people and say
well they're they're the they're the bad
ones but really
even if they are bad they're not totally
bad there's some goodness in them
every human heart or whatever you want
to call it psyche mind
is going to have some good and some bad
elements it's very rare that we run into
somebody who's like
totally completely good or totally
completely evil yeah
uh it also a little bit reminds me of
the
um what the stanford prison trial uh
experiments as well as uh you know a han
arnett's
uh the banality of evil just like seeing
how
uh you know either regularly could be
good people
do really incredibly evil things and and
other contexts that would change
yeah i i'm always a little bit leery
about
the extrapolation from the stanford
prison experiment
for two reasons one is that um i think
it tells us much more about
the the people that they were so that
they selected
you know who are college students the
other is that we know there's problems
with the study design because they came
out later on you know
but it has become sort of a trope that
you find in in everybody's psychology
and business leadership textbooks and
things like that
and and we can point to many other cases
where people have once given the
authority to do so
done bad things to to other people with
you know impunity really um
says you're uh feeling that it's
that it's not a absolute that
there's still people that will buck the
system oh yeah
yeah that's your because historically
you see that yeah yeah
although that's a quibble with it i mean
that that's that's sort of my biggest
quibble with it is that these these uh
psychological experiments very often
tell us much more about the typical
undergraduate at stanford
that they do about like the rest of the
people in the neighboring city who
weren't drawn into the experiment
you know what does that acronym is like
a white affluent
male um it's like all these experiments
are done on college students you know
yeah not so male anymore but like it
used to be as like everything was just
like a whole bunch of
affluent white guys yeah and and you can
even say
the generalizations i mean they talk
about um
if i remember right now i don't remember
exactly how the acronym goes
but you know weird countries right um
a lot of times maybe this is a sort of a
broader topic we focus in on
a a group for study and we assume that
they stand for everybody um
as a matter of fact you know again if
you don't mind veering a little bit off
topic
somebody who i was just shooting some
some lecture videos on today david hume
the great you know skeptic 18th century
philosopher
he says some stuff that is almost
amazing
when you read it in print but but you do
see people assuming this
uh quite often and so he you know as
as much as david hume said well you
can't you know you can never know cause
and effect and
everything is just probabilities he said
that human nature is basically the same
everywhere
at every time in every culture and we
can know
all about the romans or ancient chinese
or about you know what people would be
like in the distant future
by extrapolating from ourselves you know
we can we can think about what you know
in his view englishmen in the in the
18th century are like
and the same basic motives the same
basic passions are
are you know guiding everybody it's just
you know like basically we're changing
costumes and names and stuff like that
and you know you say to yourself when
you when you read that
well how would you possibly know that
i mean even if you weren't a skeptic how
would you
possibly uh know that um
how can you go back in time and make
these these sort of
assumptions i mean the little windows
that we have into what was happening
saying roman society
are very small and and far between right
and it's mostly the ruling class that we
know about so like exactly
society like in the on the street yeah i
mean that's why the discipline of
cultural history developed you know and
the focus on like looking at
uh material artifacts and and
reconstructing what it was
like for for other people other than
just the the
writers of the chronicles and but i
think this is a very common thing
it's not just david hume who thinks that
you can do this
i think that that many people
are prone to assume that if you know
this group here
you can you can easily imprint that
or infer from that to what any other
group would be like so coming back to
the stanford princeton experiment
well it doesn't really matter that we
we've just got a bunch of college
students and no townies
in the experiment it's just fine you
know uh
we can we can judge uh what what people
will do on that basis and then
you know once it gets into what we could
call the collective hopper
of stuff that's taken as as true
then everybody else picks it up and they
do so unquestioningly
as if that was a problem with the
reconstruction of the re um
when you do another experiment and it's
not actually uh replication
yeah i mean the social sciences seem to
have a pretty bad track record when it
comes to a lot of these
um really important you know
there's a word for it not flagship but
but something along those lines
keynote experiments right
like power poses uh was one of the
yeah the big ones you know everyone
loved it it was that big ted talk and
then
no one could replicate it well i mean
since we're already off topic really
my my own personal point of view is if
it's actually in a ted talk
it's probably wrong you know because
what happened and again this
we can bring it we can circle back to
our topic what are ted talks they're
these very produced
ways of talking their their own genre
you're supposed to have slides behind
you you come up with some catchy
intro i've actually given you know a ted
style talk and and there were people
like coaching me on
you need to take out all this content
here it was about anger management you
know
people aren't going to want to hear
quite so much and i was like well this
is kind of important stuff
you know and if they had their druthers
it would have been reduced to 10 minutes
of
complete you know uh sound bite drivel
you know and and when when you listen to
ted talks when it's about something that
you don't really know that much about
you're like oh yeah that's really cool
that sounds good
when you actually know the topic you're
like wow
this is off base and people are going to
really draw draw the wrong conclusions
about this this stuff because they left
out this
and this sweeping claim that they made
doesn't hold up you know they've got to
make all sorts of qualifications and i
think we can say the same thing
coming back to our topic about labeling
people as good and bad
you know it's sort of the the equivalent
of
ted talk um culture where we're like
well that person
we don't say good or bad and ted talks
we're like innovative
amazing mind-blowing synergy exactly
yeah yeah so you know coming back to
good and bad
yeah the basic idea here is there's
usually this
false dichotomy of a good or bad that
either someone is a good person or a bad
person whereas there's
definitely a a spectrum here or maybe
a spectrum's not even good but like look
at their
the the aggregate of their actions
and you can label each one of those
actions good or bad
uh yeah and and it's not just actions
too that we have to think about it's
also like motivational structure
you know which might be revealed by what
they're doing consistently over time and
what they seem to value or they might
just come straight out and tell you
like i'm doing you know these these
actions that are being viewed as good
but i'm only doing them because i'm a
selfish
person who wants you to like me you know
or like i'm a you know unfettered
capitalist i just you know i'm gonna
give you a product at the
the lowest price possible because i want
money and there you know there's no
exterior motive besides him yeah
increasing his own wealth you know it's
based on avarice yeah although
it's funny it there's a lot of people
who portray themselves as being
worse people than they are in terms of
their motivational
structures because they've been told
that they need to do that sort of thing
you know like um you think about well
think about it as in like getting ahead
in
business yeah if you're in
a very competitive field you're not
going to say something like
you know i want to make a lot of money
so that i can be a philanthropist later
on and not just so i can like get
invited to luncheons with important
people
and you know have a statue of me in the
town hall i actually want to like make
people's lives better like you know
build libraries or you know hospitals or
something like that
if you were to say that like in certain
business areas people look at you and be
like well i don't trust that guy
you know um i want i want everyone to be
just you know just in it for the money
and and i think there's there's
guys who pretend to be tougher than they
are um
when they're they're secretly doing good
deeds on the side and they don't want
anyone to know that you know we could go
on and on with examples
right there there are people who who
portray themselves as
more selfish or worse than they they
actually are
and why do they do that because they
they think if they don't do that
something worse will happen
right right uh and and so this idea of
like
we touched on it a little bit before
like good people transferring their
uh goodness or badness i guess uh on to
their actions yeah and and like i
don't want to go and bring about
godwin's law but i am
you yeah say what it is though uh
godwin's laws uh like
uh in any internet discussion there will
uh
always be a point where someone brings
up hitler
if it goes on long enough right i think
yeah um and so
so you're skipping to the right ahead to
that that point yeah yeah
okay or maybe on the the whole of wisdom
for life as a podcast we've now hit it
[Laughter]
so hitler is absolutely reprehensible
on about as far down that like bad end
of this good bad spectrum as we possibly
can
but he did love his dog and so like
loving your dog is a bad thing
i guess that's not how i usually uh
represent that action
um but if if you use the uh idea
that the bad person uh transfers his
badness to all of his actions
are all actions then uh his loving
of a dog is a bad which i just doesn't
seem to compete with reality
you know i've seen people doing this
with um vegetarianism because hitler was
a vegetarian
so they're like oh you don't want to be
like that guy you know
and and there's there are so many
arguments that are made that way where
and i think in a lot of cases the person
doesn't really believe that
the action is that way they're doing it
for rhetorical purposes
but they'll say well you know hitler did
this so therefore you you know you doing
this sort of thing
you know hitler breathed oxygen so
you really you got to find like nitrogen
or hydrogen or something some other
alternative to that
i mean it gets quite ridiculous when you
go that far
you know in in in my classes
i usually don't let students talk about
hitler
in part because it's it's too easy we
all know that he was bad
so you know saying that some sort of
action is like an action that hitler or
the nazis would do
you know it there's a kind of sloppy
lazy thinking associated with that that
we want to encourage our students to get
away from
and i don't let them do stalin because
that's the next one that they'll go to
you know you got to be interesting uh
well the impaler or uh caligula
yeah i mean you've gotta you've gotta
have
in order to to make these classes
effective learning situations there's
got to be messier
more complicated examples to
to work with you know that's also why i
don't i don't do trolley problems in
class too because
it's too it's too little cut and dried
you know i want
i want complex situations like our messy
screwed up lives and
and our uh
hard to make good decisions about you
know
personalities and actions and
motivational structures
so i guess since we're talking about
like bad people
what yeah what is the problem with
calling other people bad
and this results in a number of
potential pitfalls one
we've already figured out here is it's
you know it might be rhetorically useful
sometimes but it's definitely not uh
rational to make these associations
between
a good or bad person however you want to
find that and their actions
um and uh
and we we also talked about this idea of
like what is
um why do people do bad ideas and
we can uh pull from the amino
the plato's amino discussion on um
oh i actually had that just in place
over here um
about why people do the good or the bad
yeah yeah and this is raising
the the issue of um um
how people who know what in general what
the good is how they wind up doing bad
things right
yeah so uh you know this is uh
everyone desires the good this is a
socrates position
and only do bad things because they have
to deceive themselves into thinking that
the bad they're doing
is good and this kind of comes from this
conversation between meno and socrates
where they're discussing
what is virtue and at one point in time
meno says
the virtue is desiring fine things and
being able to acquire them and
socrates is like oh yes well i've got
something to come back
at you with that it's like um
so those who don't recognize bad things
for what they are
don't desire bad but what they think is
good though in fact it is bad
those who through ignorance mistake bad
things for good
um obviously desire the good does it do
they not
um and i think you you push back against
this at some points
um you mean in terms of like making it
into a sort of
sweeping covers everything principle to
describe things yeah i mean i i do
i personally i do think that there are
some people who
will will recognize something as bad in
some sense
and they will still want it pursue it
you know
we can think about addicts for example
as as one class of people
they if they're not too far gone they
know that what they're addicted to is
is bad for them at least maybe bad in
general
and that they should avoid it but they
find themselves compelled to and then
they feel bad about it afterwards they
feel regret and shame and
things like that but there's other
people who are you know like you think
about the sadist who
desires to inflict pain and humiliation
on another person
if you go to them and you say well you
know you're really just mistaken about
you know
what's good and bad don't you understand
that inflicting pain is a bad thing look
at how that person's suffering over
there
and they're like yeah that's exactly
what i want i like that over there
and then you know so your first approach
to them
is is unsuccessful now you can like bump
it up to another level
which i think we have to do in some of
these cases and say well see that person
has got a distortion
in another way they think that you know
doing things that are that they know to
be bad is actually good
so that you could say well they still do
pursue the good but it's a more
complicated structure it's not so simple
as well there's just this
easy mistake that they made and we can
steer them and show oh it's not nice to
hurt other people
wouldn't you have a better life if you
got along with everyone
you know there are some people who are
like no i hate everybody else
um i want to make their lives miserable
that will be my
my uh that will be what will make me
feel
happy or good um so one of the the
worst examples of saying someone
thinking that they're doing the good was
uh the whole eugenics movement like oh
we're gonna make a better human race by
you know uh murdering people and i'm
like castrating them or at least
interesting when you read
the stuff that those people were
writing like in in letters to each other
or or saying
there was that idealistic aspect to it
right
you know you got to break some omelettes
to make it make good eggs and we're
going to get rid of all the bad eggs and
we can
mix metaphors all we want right so there
is that side
and then there were other people you
always get some people who are like this
this is going to be a good
vehicle for me to do the things that i
want to do to other people because i
hate those people
you know i can't wait to see them wiped
off the face of the earth
and there was there's a good bit of that
in there as well
um you know anytime that you see a
reference to
uh you know mongrels or things like that
you got to like be
you know your ears kind of prick up and
you're like
i don't know that that's just a um
genteel word for what they consider to
be lower
and there's no emotional investment in
their on their part
that that's kind of looking forward to
getting rid of that whole group of
people
um so i think there's you know with any
movement
like that there's there's a complicated
set of motives and the same person
could start out with one set of motives
and then
emerge five years later with another set
of motives
you know maybe i mean we do we do see
this sometimes people get into things
for one set of reasons and then they
come out
after having had certain experiences on
the other side with
with others i'll give you an example
that's that that's a good transformation
when i was teaching
at indiana state prison in the ball
state you know
uh prison college thing where they'd
earn a four-year degree
they they got eight semesters and that
was it
on the grant that they were being given
by by the state of indiana
and a lot of the prisoners would come in
and you'd ask them you know
they'd be kind of a pain in your class
you'd be like why are you here
and they'd be like i want to get out of
the cell you know
this is something to do or i'm
interested in the time cut that i'm
going to get because they would get if
they got an associates they'd get
one year off their sentence and a
bachelor would take another two years
and some of those guys would be like
that two years into their
their education and i would see the same
guys because i was one of the few people
who taught philosophy and religious
studies classes there
so i'd get the same guys in my classes
and then every once in a while you'd see
this turnaround happen
where they realized that education was
actually a good thing
and that that you know they'd been
wasting their time up until now
kind of like pushing against us and now
they wanted to get as much knowledge
out of us and the classes and the
materials as possible
and sometimes they'd express regrets
they'd be like man i kind of like
you know i got my good grades but i
didn't learn that much
in the first two years because i was
trying to cut corners and
you know i didn't i wasn't receptive
i've only got two more years left i got
to make the most out of this now those
are two very different motivational
structures right
and the same thing could happen with any
sort of
any sort of cause i think that must be
really gratifying for that you know
turnaround to happen
yeah and it's completely contingent you
know what it does
you know it's not like you can it's not
like you could produce a class that
would
would do that you you know like when
they talk about with therapy a person
has to want
to make progress it's the same way with
i think
personal development you can you can
like give them all sorts of resources
but until something happens where
they're like oh i wanna i want a
different course for my life it's not
gonna it's not gonna make any difference
so i think a lot of it depended on what
was happening in the cell blocks
you know so back to good and bad yeah
yeah
calling other people bad um we don't
find a person
and um it's almost
no person can be that perfect good
person
and we're all gonna like fail at some
point in time
and so it's really hard to you know say
if
if the good person is always good
then almost no one on earth
or no one on earth ever um has actually
lived up to this moniker and so it'd be
really hard if you
if that's impractical to you standard
yeah this also comes out of a platonic
dialogue
the fedo where socrates is talking with
his friends
shortly before his execution in the
prison cell in
athens and he cautions them against what
he calls mythology
and he's going to use misanthropy as
a way to understand mythology misology
is a distrust of arguments
and or or of accounts right so logos is
his argument misos is hatred and he says
we don't have to worry too much about
that we could probably talk about that
another time
the misanthropy part um socrates says
how do people become
misanthrope misanthrope misanthropes
right
misanthropic yeah there we go um what
ends up
it's a process they they make a bunch of
mistakes
mistakes in uncritically
assuming people to be good and so
instead of realizing that the majority
of people
are are not good or bad exclusively
they're somewhere in the middle like you
mentioned a spectrum maybe they are
on a genuine spectrum or maybe it's sort
of like there's a lot of good and
bad interfused or they're good some of
the time and bad some of the time
it's very rare we find somebody who's
like good all the time or somebody who's
bad all the time
although maybe they you know maybe we do
encounter some who are kind of close to
the edge i don't think we ever i
see the perfect type you know so
socrates says
that people are are
foolish and imprudently
trust people who are not completely good
as if they were completely good
and what's going to happen if you do
that well you're going to get let down
maybe you get taken advantage of you
know and i think
a lot of us have lived through that sort
of thing you know we make friends with
people
and and we're we we really want our
friends to be good people so we assume
that they are
and then they don't pick us up when they
say that they're going to or they
you know they uh walk out after
you're running a tab or whatever it
happens to be you know
it's moving day they don't show up you
know or they
they only show up at the after
everything's been moved and then they
eat your pizza and drink your beer
you know so that happens over and over
and over again
and with each person the the the person
who's going to become a misanthrope
doesn't learn the lesson
because the lesson would be you know i
trust this person and they let me down
oh maybe i shouldn't place so much trust
maybe i shouldn't assume
that they're they're the wonderful you
know friend or whoever
benefactor that i thought they were with
a heart of gold and
all those sorts of things maybe i should
you know look at them realistically
instead they go on to the next person
and then you do exactly the same thing
and then clarify yeah you said this
happens over and over and over again and
you're referring to
different individual peoples that they
place their trust and then their trust
is
broken instead of one person constantly
breaking their trust over and over again
well that would be at that point but at
least at that point you you'd have a
much better
uh reasoning to maybe cut that person
out here you know i mean there are
people who
well yeah i mean that's a great point
there are people who do that
they they come back to the same screwed
up person over and over again
treat them as if they're an angel get
screwed over by them
and then they're shocked and surprised
once again
you know but yeah with plato it's it's
multiple people
and eventually they get to the point
where they like something
something switches and they go all the
way to the other side and they say
people are
all bad you know and so misanthropy is
is hatred of other human beings but it's
hatred because you think they're bad
you know so why trust anybody people are
all
you know evil or bad or they're all
going to let you down and then that
that's
just uncritical of a position as the one
that thinks that everybody's good
you know it's much better just to be
realistic about it
and say well if i don't know somebody
they're probably
belonging here in the middle part
between good and evil
if if i'm in you know an area where i
know people are all
antagonistic like certain job settings
well maybe i should actually assume that
they're generally bad
although i shouldn't assume that they're
all like the epitome of evil
you know yeah they might go home to
their you know family and they're like
really good there but like within the
context of that job there
who knows yeah i was just thinking i was
just thinking of a rick and morty
cartoon
you've seen yes so uh the one who's
modeled after freddy krueger i forget
oh i forget his name but he's uh chasing
them around
on our radio show here no but he's got
what like scissors
not scissors but something on his on his
fingers yeah and
uh he uh he's chasing them around saying
you can run but you can't hide i'm gonna
kill you etc etc
and then like he clocks out goes home to
his wife and
kid and they've all got the things on
their hands too
and um you know and he's a perfect model
of a a father
well first he screws up remember oh yeah
he brings his work
stress home and says uh something mean
to his wife and she like you know
uh yells at him a bit and he's like oh
yeah i'm sorry you know
didn't mean to bring it home with me so
yeah so i want to go to the the pitfalls
on the other side of calling
other people good and um when you call
someone another person good you support
of them implicitly basically and you can
fall into the trap of calling
all of their actions good and you can
attribute the value of good
to profoundly evil acts and we've seen
this
um throughout history over and over and
over again a lot of times when we have
people in power especially within on
religious settings or academic settings
or anywhere there's a large power
dynamic
commercial settings too i think you know
think about all the people who
lost their life savings the staff of
enron
you know because they they wanted to be
good company people and they looked at
this guy
kenneth lay and all of his cronies and
they seem really good people you know
they wouldn't screw us over
bernie
it's interesting i read something an
interview with him
where at one point he wanted to like try
to cut it off which would have meant the
ponzi scheme would have collapsed at
that point
and he couldn't he couldn't get people
to not
want to invest with him
so yeah um and so
and we've got a lot of examples of
people that were at least
at one point considered good and or
others that are still considered good
but they have
certain aspects to them that are not as
good and so
yeah um bill cosby we got
the whole catholic priest issue on
mlk a great person but had an
extramarital affair and it was used
against him by his political opponents
uh thomas jefferson you know uh slaves
plus
sally hemmings on alexander hamilton
another extra extramarital affair on
many gurus uh bikram uh what do you know
about that
oh well he he uh you know like a lot of
these these
people who uh develop a following
and are innovators in some way right i
think that there's there's something
about innovator culture that that does
this they
they're gonna like take whatever is
available and
uh turn it up to 11 to use spinal taps
phrase so bikram is the
one of these people who started doing
hot yoga
and you know some of the people
involved in the movement started saying
well this guy is engaging in sexual
harassment or actually you know
uh full-on sexual misconduct and and you
know
the dynamic then is oh you can't talk
bad about the leader
because he's so wonderful people want to
you know change the subject to all the
good things that this
this person is doing and when you you
know when you are a
whistleblower or you are reporting
somebody
engaging in you know wrongful behavior
towards yourself
you often get quite isolated within
these communities
and but then what ends up happening you
know they they
push some of the allegations under the
proverbial rug
and the person is still going to keep
doing what they're doing sometimes
emboldened by it
and eventually it all does come out and
then the people who were originally
pushed out are vindicated in a way but
usually not in a way where the you know
like in a movie oh it's a wonderful
ending and they walk
off into the sunset they're still you
know dealing with the trauma of having
been
told that they're the bad people you
know
and may in fact even even believe it
themselves
and we see this with with organization
after organization after organization
it doesn't have to be a religious or
political
organization it can be a union it can be
you know well we were talking about this
this case of
the ethicist thomas poga right who was
kind of a big name
in analytic uh philosophy and ethics
well it turned out he was sexually
harassing graduate students and coercing
them
and um you know again their allegations
were
typically dismissed oh how can you you
know and people would say things like
how can you say this about him his
articles are so good
and and you know um it turns out that
that he was kind of a rotten
person in that respect probably again
not like totally evil
i'm sure he he did so a lot of good for
other people but he
he did some clearly wrong actions
that hurt a lot of other people and and
created an environment where
um not only you know it's
when people like that do that it's not
only that they're doing bad
actions by themselves which which is
already bad enough
but the hypocrisy involved um
scandalizes so many other people and
gets them to think well there's nothing
to these
these institutions everybody in them is
bad
sort of like the misanthropy thing that
we're seeing right you know
um so you know
the good uh caviar not caveat the good
uh
nugget that we can definitely come from
this is that we
uh should definitely not listen uh
listen to someone like
totally uncritically and yeah
unconditionally
you know you you really uh should you
know especially if you've got a feeling
that this might be right you know or
this might be wrong
to like take a step back you know and
realize that people can
you know even if you have hold them in
high reverence can do some really
weird and potentially evil things
so i want to go to calling yourself good
okay
um do you wanna you wanna call yourself
good right now or
uh uh how about goodish
okay there you go moving towards good
um and um
so i guess within the the stoic
tradition at least the ancient stokes a
lot of them called themselves
uh procoptin which is those who are
uh progressing towards a goal and so the
the per coptin strives towards a
continual progress towards
the perfection of the idea of the stoic
sage
and so you can say take the same idea
and like apply it to your
own individual stated values and say
it's like okay i want to be a person
that really exemplifies
these things because that's what i
consider to be the ideal of a good
person
and and you work at doing this thing
because you know once again
we're not perfect and we fail and a lot
of our
motivation sometimes gets muddied uh
by you know our biases yeah
you know i think that's kind of a
constant in any sort of virtue ethics
approach
this um you know it's kind of funny too
because you look at it from the outside
i think a lot of people who are
attracted to virtue ethics originally
they're like
okay how can i be virtuous right now you
know and you're like well it doesn't
work like that you know
first you gotta like come in who you are
you're kind of messed up you probably
don't know all the things that are
off with you you probably think you have
some of the good traits that you you do
have
are being obscured by other good traits
that aren't really good
but you've just you're just using to
compensate for stuff so now we
start engaging in analysis and trying to
look at our habits and what we're doing
and we use the text
to help us out and then um
you know you you you become a little
less screwed up
right and then the tendency is to think
oh man i've made it now
i'm totally virtuous you know and that's
just not how it works it's a continual
process you know i think there's a lot
of people who approach
ethics in general as if it's like
ticking off a bunch of boxes
you know and if you can just do that
then you're you're a goodie
and and you you don't have to do
anything anymore you've
been certified you know and so this is
the the crux of the issue is kind of
this idea between
a a stagnant mindset versus a growth
mindset and so stagnant mindset is like
oh yeah i've ticked all of all my boxes
i'm good
i don't have to work anymore whereas the
growth mindset says that you basically
you always have
some ability to improve upon yourself
and
you know in many aspects you know be it
ethics or like you want to be an artist
and so you want to draw every day or
what there's
there's a billion different things that
we can try to become
experts at um and uh
and we're not like just given certain
innate abilities some people do have
you know innate abilities like usain
bolt
uh definitely has the the body type to
be a very good runner
i will never be as good of runner as
usain bolt is but i can be a much better
runner than i am right now
yeah it's like epictetus said maybe i
can't be socrates but i can at least be
a better epictetus right
right you know it's interesting one of
the people i do a lot of work on is
saint anselm of canterbury
and i you know he had he left behind
these prayers and meditations
um which were circulated around europe
actually among nobility and clergy
because what he did some really
interesting stuff in the rhetoric of
prayer
and when you read this stuff and you
look at his biography
he talks about himself he's he's talking
to to god or to the saints and he's
you know supposed to be like unveiling
who he is and it turns out that
um he's in his view not that good of a
guy and he needs help
he needs he needs to be restored to some
sort of integrity
he uses you know ideas like his soul
having
uh sores and ulcerations on it
from from his bad actions and now when
you read his biography you realize this
guy didn't really do many bad actions
he was actually a pretty good guy as a
matter of fact in many respects he was
quite exemplary
and he was even humble about being
exemplary without being sort of a fake
humility and stuff like that
so what's the disconnect between these
right well
there's a there's an easy answer for
that which is he made a lot of progress
and the more progress that you actually
do make in terms of moral goodness
the more you start to see other things
other parts of yourself that until then
you weren't ready to really face
and now you can actually see them and
you're like oh
man it's sort of like you know like when
you're building a house
you know uh or you're rehabbing a house
and you uh you know you think you've got
one thing to fix
and then you like i don't know you pull
up some carpet and you're like oh
there's some nice floors under here
let me go down in the basement take a
look at the the joists oh
man they're rotten we're gonna have to
replace those and then as you're
replacing them you find something else
that's kind of screwed up
well that's that's the way um that's the
way it works in personal development
you know uh and and you're right it
could also be like
musical talent or something like that
the better you get the more you realize
what you're not able to do
and you're aware of all these different
aspects that you never were aware
as just a casual listener of music yeah
i mean could you say that there's i mean
the stoics talk about philosophy is the
art of living
right so could we generalize that more
and say that
being able to discern between what's
genuinely good and bad
is something that takes us a long time
to
to develop and we we tend to screw it up
quite a bit you know
yeah but it's at least it gives us a
road map for like
they say you acquire virtue in order
to lead a a eudaimonic life or like a a
virtuous life leads to a udemonic life
or a life that is
of an excellent human a flourishing yeah
flourishing
and um and these are the
the things that you should probably be
focusing on if you want to be
a flourishing human being uh
but they are uh good in and of
themselves
yeah it's i mean this is again a little
bit off topic but it seems like there's
so many roads so many approaches leading
towards that you know even within a one
particular
tradition like say stoicism
there's so many different practices that
you can apply that that lead into
that no no single one of them is like
the
the magic bullet as they say right right
it's
a cornucopia of different things that
when put together yeah tends to increase
on your excellence as a human to get you
closer to a more
fulfilling life um so this the problem
is is very
attention it takes attention to actually
look at yourself in a really critical
manner
to be aware of your present actions and
your present desires and your pres
present impressions um but a constant
attention is
really hard uh for a number of
uh reasons but like one of them is like
just our biology and
so herbert a simon is a nobel prize
winning
economist for the idea of bounded
rationality
and this is kind of goes against this
idea of
homo economicus which was kind of like
the the ideal of a
a man that is personally rational and so
like the
the economics like oh yeah well if you
know we've got this personal
uh perfectly rational set of people and
they all make perfectly rational
arguments or like decisions and that's
how we're going to uh model economics
which is
not any way in concordance with uh
reality yeah yeah um and and so his
boundary rationality was
some work that he uh helped before that
like
you know shows that every second we get
about 11 million pieces of different
information
presented to us through our different
senses and we only have about
enough attention to be conscious of
about 40 of them and all the others are
uh our brain uses heuristics in a
non-conscious portion of us to say like
well that's
not useful at all i'm going to ignore
that or on
hey that stick on the ground that looks
like a snake you should really paint
things into each other yeah like
presents that's your more conscious mind
and and this idea that like there's so
much information that we're making all
these unconscious decisions about
um is uh if we're if we have
bad heuristics uh then these bad
heuristics result
in really um potentially bad outcomes
yeah and you know attention is something
that can be
developed i mean that's what meditative
practices typically do
the stoics um we're not sure exactly
what they did in terms of that we know
that they had
practices that they were using and they
they stressed what they called prosoque
which would translate as attention but
but
could also be translated as mindfulness
or
something along those lines but it is
very difficult to do it
for any sustained period and it's like
it's like a muscle that you have to
have to build um somebody who's
you know you'd expect would be like
totally about
all attention all the time who
surprisingly says you can't do that is
rene descartes
the great 16th century mathematician and
philosopher
you know people who read descartes
usually read
the discourse on method and and the
meditations and often only read the
first two meditations and they get this
idea you know i think therefore i am
right so he's thinking all the time
so when he's writing to this brilliant
woman princess elizabeth of bohemia
who um had raised some problems for
for cartesian metaphysics and and
philosophy of mind
he actually tells her at one point that
most of the time
what we're doing is not like the pure
work of the intellect
it's actually our imagination drawn from
you know
sense things right we're not doing this
purely reflexive
um metacognitive thing um
and he says you can maybe do that like
one hour a month
if you've if you're trained so this is
descartes
yeah you know somebody who has been
training himself
definitely had like natural abilities um
i mean the guy was solving you know
unsolved algebraic uh
equations as a young student in order to
like get to sleep in it was like a deal
that he made with his
his uh like the rector of the school
that he was at so he had
he had everything going for him and even
he's saying yeah you can't do this all
that often
so now how does that tie in with with
good and bad and viewing ourselves
as as good and bad um so the idea here
is
uh one of the things that maybe like go
down this little rabbit hole was
a professor dolly chung over at nyu
um who's has this on
her i guess her rallying caller like her
her core ideas
to move yourselves to the idea of
calling ourselves good-ish
and good just so that we are really
constantly aware that we do have the
ability to
um increase that we have the ability to
grow as
uh humans and um does she talk about the
possibility of backsliding too or
um if we're not like choosing to focus
or
yeah uh i did not see that so um
does not mean that she does not though
yeah i'm just not aware
well do we do we want to talk about the
the practice that we think would help to
promote this then
yeah because we're getting close to the
end of our time
yeah so um reserving judgments is a
practice
uh that i believe is in several
traditions
as well as stoics on this the idea to
instead of when you see someone um
oh drunk in public there's actually a a
very
uh uncommon condition where people
actually ferment
um grains in their belly so they're not
actually drinking any alcohol
but their body is producing alcohol and
they're getting drunk anyways
wow um which is a very very uncommon
thing but
the idea is that you don't always know
all of
the story and there could be lots of
reasons
behind why someone is acting in a way
that you would
call them good or bad yeah categorizing
them right
i mean somebody could be drunk in public
and it could be well it was their
birthday and they hung out with a bunch
of friends who were all
heavy drinkers and they were the
lightweight and there you go
or um you know somebody just broke up
with them and
they're drowning their sorrows that's
not something they do every single day
and
and you know we could say this about a
whole bunch of other things too or we
see people do it doing things where
we're like
yeah i don't like people who do that
they're bad you know
we would we would say well you know
we're not going to say that they
epictetus says don't say that somebody
drinks badly
say that they drink you know more than
they should
there's there's a very different um
value
assigned to each of those one is more
factual one is much more
morally imbued and we can then take this
and apply it to ourselves because of
this idea of
the bounded rationality and we may not
have
uh like conscious awareness of some of
the things that we do and we
we might realize that we have done
something bad and we can't just cause
like oh now i'm a bad person
it's like no i have the ability to be a
better person
because i have actually looked at myself
and
found something there
yeah yeah there's i think there
we could actually do a whole other show
about
how people do improve themselves through
you know focusing and discerning what
they want to work on
but it looks like we have to draw this
one to a close
so we're going to leave you with the
words seneca the younger
we we should seek out the knowledge and
tools
which are capable of immediate practical
application and learn them so well that
words become
[Music]
works
[Music]
you